many people ask me questions about stoic
philosophy and practice I've created
this series to provide short answers to
the most common recurring or confusing
questions about stoicism the question is
which book should I read first and it's
specifically about stoic literature this
came up in Facebook but it's a great
question about philosophy in general
it's a common concern that many people
have they want to begin with the right
book or the best book or the book that's
going to lay down the proper foundation
for all of their future studies and I
have a few things to say about this the
shortest answer to this question is that
there isn't any book that you should
start with there is no right book there
is no best book there is no
one-size-fits-all piece of literature
that you should begin your studies of
Stoicism with now if I were a beginner
wanting to get into stoicism and I asked
that question and I got that answer I
would say wait a second dr. Sandler that
is profoundly unhelpful what are you
talking about so let me give a longer
explanation that's gonna range over a
few points let's begin by saying that in
a way this frees you up you can read
whatever book is going to be helpful for
you I strongly suggest that at some
point in time you're going to want to
actually read the classic stoic text and
by that I mean epictetus Seneca Marcus
Aurelius but you can begin if it works
for you with some of the more popular
stoic literature that's out there but
you know understand that you're you're
getting somebody else's interpretation
rather than the original source material
and that's okay now why should I as a
scholar researcher on stoicism adopt
such a Leslie ferrule might even say
lackadaisical attitude towards what you
ought to read it's not just because it
has to do with you
as an individual reader who can make
their own decisions about what they want
to read it's also because I think it's
good to get out of the way this notion
that by reading the right text at the
beginning you're going to save yourself
a lot of trouble or set down the right
foundation or at least not get things
wrong about stoicism that's not really
the case as a matter of fact when it
comes to philosophical literature you
should expect that the first time that
you read something you're probably not
even going to get half of what's going
on in that book and you're probably
gonna have to go back to it and you'll
miss remember things and that's
perfectly fine that's normal that's the
way it works that happens even with me
today you know rereading
Epictetus after 25 years maybe even more
of reading him I still find stuff in
there that I missed the last time around
and that is okay so if that happens to
me it's gonna happen to you what you
should expect is whatever book you pick
you're gonna read that and it may be
very helpful for you and then you're
gonna read some other stuff and that's
gonna tell you more about stoicism then
you're gonna come back to that first
book and read it again and you're going
to get more out of it the second time
and instead of like laying down a solid
foundation that you're going to be
building on think of it more as an
iterative process where you're you're
getting closer and closer and closer to
understanding what it is that these
authors are trying to communicate to you
this iterative ongoing process of
reading and really discovery is
something that is even more applicable
to practical philosophy which is what
stoicism is it's a philosophy of life so
you can begin with Epictetus is
enchiridion and then you know read a
popular book or read you know another
classic stoic texts like maybe Senecas
on anger and then come back to epictetus
and you're going to find that you
understand more that you've acquired
something in the process you might go
from epictetus is enchiridion into his
discourses or you might read one of the
great secondary works on Epictetus or on
stoicism in general all of that is
perfectly fine it doesn't matter so much
what book you start with what matters is
whether you're making a sort of ongoing
commitment to studying stoicism because
you can't get a full perspective on
stoicism from any of the secondary
literature works out there let alone the
popular ones and you also can't get it
just from epictetus or just from Seneca
or just from marcus aurelius you if you
really want to understand stoicism
you've got to do some reading around and
you've got to do some rereading and
that's great because again the more
times you do that the more you will be
rewarded with developing a better and
better understanding so hopefully
hearing that answer you feel kind of a
sense of relief and and liberation
rather than just confusion and wishing
that I'd said one book in particular if
you found this answer helpful for you
then please share it with others who
might benefit from it this work is
entirely supported by crowdfunding on my
patreon site so if you find it valuable
consider becoming a supporter at
patreon.com slash Saddler